die validierung und videos gesehen
das ist so ist sie war glaube ich doch
innovativ und ist kaffeezeit und einfach
nicht auf sagte dass er mit mir trotzdem
haben es ist selbst die krone darf mit
meiner zukunft aufzubauen was mit 58
beginnt walter nowak diese vergangenheit
langsam zu verstehen nicht so nahm sein
leben stets zuverlässig die
schlimmstmögliche wendung
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
in dieser vermeintlichen idylle in
zollikofen bei bern hat alles angefangen
und zwar denkbar schlecht
walter nowak geht nach fast 40 jahren
zum ersten mal dorthin zurück wo sein
unglück seinen lauf genommen hat
welche kollegen
zur welt gekommen ist der 1956 in wien
nach seiner geburt kehrten seine eltern
zurück in die schweiz
worin sie auf der suche nach arbeit
migriert waren
wo sie ihr büro hat sowieso
ja aber nach angaben der spruch vom
vater hat sie leider feldschlacht karte
die autofahrer immer und immer wieder
kommt ja das ist klassische peter bruch
gegangen ist obwohl mittlerweile sicher
sagte das ist nicht aus ich sehe das ist
der unterschied von manchester die
schächtungen antialkoholische und kann
jeder mensch und unabhängig sie und ich
glaube dass ich mir was wenig nach
worten
aber natürlich einfach er hat sie dass
ihre mutter lux spiel gefallen die haben
hier große sollte
das münchner trio bevor die eigentliche
metal works voraussehen wie wenig ich
gesehen was passiert ist wenn ihr
verantwortlich gesehen
nowak auf seinem alten fluchtweg
richtung an seine mutter hatte bald
einen neuen mann gefunden einen der
besser zu ihr passte einen alkoholiker
und so wurde es zu hause noch
unerträglicher und was wenn ich sehr gut
gespielt
der hat sie gelten ja das ist eine
bezugsperson gesehen und da haben wir
und groß ist ausschließlich aus auch
heute möglich geschützt und einfach den
moment als sie ist sehr frieren muss ich
verlange vertriebsleiter dagegen was
berichte und mehr belastet die welle von
vorschlägen männliche denen ich bin
heute ein jungvogel im sinn und haben
wenig hoffnung gebaut worden
damit ist und unter jesus zu büro häufig
essen holten absturz in serie nach
atlantiks mit dem kabine vorbei
ich schlafe und nichts noten wo und wie
haben ihre äcker naja ich kann den
fliegenden bauten
das ist ein moment der mir einfach nur
erinnere die erinnerungen an den rest
seiner traurigen kindheit und jugendzeit
hatte nowak jahrzehntelang in den
dunkelsten bezirk seiner seele verdammt
und sich fortan den zutritt verweigert
zu seinem eigenen schutz wie sich
herausstellen sollte denn es war alles
noch schlimmer gekommen
[Musik]
fast 30 jahre hat nowak seine
erinnerungen erfolgreich verdrängt doch
mit anfang 50 haben sie ihn eingeholt
mit hey das jährigen stamme nicht
wenigen von nicht irgendwie den mal
verträumt
die jetzt langsam mit der oberfläche
nowak war mittlerweile geschieden und
vater von zwei kindern als er nach
bludenz in vorarlberg zug direkt neben
eine kirche
und da ich aber dass ich halte die
derzeitigen gestört ich habe immer
wieder traurig ist ziemlich läuft
nowak begaben sich an die ostschweiz zu
erinnern daran dass es zu hause nicht
mehr gegangen dass er darum mit 13 ins
kloster fischingen im kanton thurgau
gekommen war und darum dass er den
keiner wollte das ideale opfer gewesen
und dort jahrelang missbraucht worden
war
[Musik]
nowak ist ein stämmiger mann aber er
spielte bald dass seine zurückkehrenden
erinnerungen in form zu reißen drohten
er brauchte hilfe und fand sie bei karin
kaufmann unwahrscheinlich wie sie die
anderen betroffenen sehr sehr oft trägt
am anfang auch sehr unsicher
viele betroffenen hatten an an schock
eigentlich normal in dem sie sich an
angel erinnern sehr depressiv eigentlich
sehr einsam sehr verzweifelt
sehr verbittert und enttäuscht von
labour sowie die am anfang lag neumayer
nowak fastet den mut zu einer anzeige
und 2012 zum gang an die öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
eine gründliche aufarbeitung brauche es
nicht ist der heutige trägervereins des
klosters damals sicher
das haben wir bisher nicht gemacht und
der vereinsvorstand hat entschieden es
weiterhin nicht zu machen und
finanzieller schadenersatz komme auch
nicht in frage wenn wir geld anbieten
ist das letztlich juristisch so etwas
wie eine schuldanerkennung
[Musik]
keine zwei wochen später wird das opfer
zum vermeintlichen täter und der
thurgauer zeitung ist von mutmasslichem
rufmord die rede
der angeschuldigte pater heute 84 denkt
laut über eine verleumdungsklage nach
der öffentliche druck bleibt das bild
indes schnell von einer
verleumdungsklage ist fortan nicht mehr
die rede
denn immer mehr ehemalige zöglinge
melden sich und besteht in nowaks
vorwürfe auch sie hätten in fischingen
alles andere als nächstenliebe und
barmherzigkeit erfahren sexuellen
übergriff zwangs dunkelhaft und gewalt
seien für viele sind zum alltag gehört
die verantwortlichen hätten sich für die
rate jetzt entschuldigt mit wort und
geld was den medien zwei jahre nach
nowaks ist im öffentlichem auftritt
vorgestellt wird belegt dass seine
träume wohl keine spielereien waren
sondern erinnerungen an das was
mittlerweile auf 170 seiten nachzulesen
ist
es ist erschütternd sie immerhin liegen
dass darin ein ideales dem recht
ergangen ist aber wenn man liest wenn
man schwarze fleece vor sich gesehen ist
es auch schon einmal sehr sehr berührend
und erschütternd der bericht ist ein
etappensieg für die betroffenen das
systematisches versagen der aufsicht und
die fehlende kontrolle sind nun
offiziell zu einem prozess kommt es
wegen der verjährung indes nicht für die
gewaltexzesse und sexuellen übergriffe
wird niemand die verantwortung
übernehmen kein seelen mord wird je
gesucht
die nord bekriegen im auto das macht es
für wie der sexuelle missbrauch ist
sicher dass otto mikros vergesse ich bin
meine schritte pc zu begrüßt da liegt
das problem
es ist auch nicht so natürlich sei sie
wie sie sagte sie
das buch eigentlich schlimmsten ist es
in der früh ist also groß teilweise eine
chance auf eines neues lager- und du
findest du kriegst aber und auch das
lavaux womit ein großes werk für mich
noch dass man gebraucht
nowak recherche zeigt er intensiv im
internet und web schnell
es handelt sich um ein globales phänomen
in der katholischen kirche mit
augenfällige parallelen unabhängig von
land und institutionen aus
eigentlich hat die mord- kramme dies
mache was sie was sie wo und wie sie ihr
geschäft für die menschheit hätte ich
mache eigentlich immer mit lux sie aber
zum ergebnis geführt hätte geschichte im
renault-team große schritte machen
erwiesen hat versprochen irgendwo klasse
gebe einen menschen macht und er zeigte
seinen charakter viele die kinder nach
schwierigen verhältnissen christliche
werte hätten vor leben sollen erkannten
in ihnen leichte opfer und machten viele
von ihnen kaputt und viele die davon
wussten schauten weg ein psychiatrisches
gutachten attestiert nowak eine
fortdauernde komplexe posttraumatische
belastungsstörung nowak beginnt sein
eigenes leben zu verstehen wieso seine
ehe scheiterte und er kein guter vater
war wieso er sich auf der suche nach
anerkennung in extremsportarten
flüchtete und sich vor 20 jahren beim
skifahren den rücken
wieso er sich selber kaputt machte und
heute iv rentner ist und unter
chronischen schmerzen leidet und wo er
seine sehnsucht nach nähe und die städte
angst davor kommen
da muss auch die harmonie das sieht
jetzt muss das vertrauen das ihr das
nicht da ist denn eine persönlich mir
doch
mit gel auf der garten wohlfühlen das
dann nicht neu wenn man das ehemalige
schmutzig sind unbedingt tragen 2 1970
wurde nowak nach münsterlingen gebracht
in die psychiatrische klinik da wahre 14
im kloster war aufgefallen dass seine
schulleistungen stark nachgelassen
hatten
heute ist klar eine folge des
missbrauchs
es ist natürlich möglich das
unerfreuliche erlebnisse diese
depressive störung ausgelöst haben wurde
in münsterlingen festgehalten
diesen unerfreulichen erlebnissen ging
jedoch niemand nach vielmehr tritt das
schicksal nowak ins nächste unglück in
form von medikamenten versuchen
[Musik]
roland kuhn der damalige klinikdirektor
testete zu jener zeit medikamente am
lebenden objekt auch an kindern an
kindern wie walter nowak dass einige
dieser medikamente noch nicht mal einen
namen hatten und cool sie inständig sich
ändern wird kombination verabreichte ist
kein zufall
nowak war wohl eines seiner
versuchskaninchen
das thurgauer staatsarchiv soll nun
helfen das eigene leben weiter zu
rekonstruieren und zu verstehen
nowak will fakten sprich seine
krankenakte was sich da muss man sie
aber das ist eigentlich eine aussage wo
die bühne wo die party gemacht die zu
gestorben das erhöht die leute ich kann
ihnen sagen wir halten eine edition
gestellt da sind diese verstörenden
bilder auf seinen träumen
der 14 jährige walter weinbeck gefesselt
und da sind all die tabletten die ihm
verabreicht werden
in seinem kopf lichtet sich der nebel in
den vorhandenen unterlagen jedoch kaum
ein wort davon
ich brauche ich weiß nicht wenn es sagt
ja der medikamente studie teil
woher wissen sie das auch sagen da muss
ich sagen so habe es in fischingen auch
angefangen sagt nowak fast aussichtslos
da gibt es nur eines ordners sein und
weiter kämpfen
zermürbt sieht das nicht vor ja es gibt
schon noch was
wo ist er
levy
osv
ja
nun bewegt sich doch etwas tief unter
dem thurgau staatsarchiv lagert nämlich
rang uns privat nach haus
mittlerweile ist er geordnet und
elektronisch erfasst und der kanton
thurgau wie lean aufarbeiten lassen
er enthält listen mit namen von
versuchspersonen berichte über
testreihen und die verwendeten
substanzen
mittlerweile ist belegt nowak war damals
tatsächlich in münsterlingen auch das
waren nicht nur träumen
und klar ist weiter das cool mit
pharmafirmen wie geige und ciba geigy
zusammenarbeitete später aufgegangen in
der heutigen novartis was würden sie
sich wünschen von der firma wie novartis
das zurück was user betrifft mit der
öffentlichkeit damit wir überhaupt mal
was das wäre überhaupt hat das mache ich
verstehe gar nicht verstorben
novak hat viele fragen aber war dies
etwa war ihnen bekannt dass ihre
medikamente auch an kindern getestet
wurden wurde kontrolliert ob kunden die
damaligen auflagen für medikamententests
einhielt und entschädigen sie opfer für
ihre spätfolgen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt verzichten wir
auf eine stellungnahme schreibt novartis
nowak und einige mitstreiter kämpfen
weiter heute vor dem uno-sitz in genf
staaten wie die schweiz sollen ihre
aufsicht zu unterlassungen anerkennen
und ich ehemaligen heim und verdient
kindern eine entschädigung zahlen
der einzige vertreter lässt sich kurz
zeigt ist die polizei sie mich zwar
schlechter als das was man ein fertiges
machen will
nowak selber leitet unter anderem an
einem viel zu hohen blutdruck in den
akten taucht zwei jahre nach dem beginn
der medikamenten versuche da ist der 16
erstmals ein entsprechender hinweise auf
nowak lebte seite damit und es wurde
immer schlimmer
trotzdem machte er im märz die stets
einen weiten bogen eine unbewusste angst
aus der zeit in münsterlingen
und nun ist er doch im spital auf
eigenen wunsch das unglück scheint ihn
einmal mehr eingeholt zu haben er hat
seit monaten bauchschmerzen und neu auch
blut im stuhl
er muss eine darmspiegelung machen
lassen
dadurch schwierig mit dem gedanken dass
das endlich passiert wie - ring passiert
ist ist im moment wie vor
aber es lag also aber schlimm für morgen
sonntag gründlich untersucht werden das
erste mal seit jahrzehnten in einigen
tagen sollen die ergebnisse vorliegen
ich glaube jedem ist dann habe es war
volkmann wenn der polizei gesichert sei
und sie angst vorm tod nedas andrews
erlöse gar nicht dass ich zurzeit
johannes rohstoff wie depressiv und
liegen deshalb glaube ich so dass das
dort ohne musiker sich das nach china
investiere und auch weil ich gegen
radprofis die erste untersuchung verlief
ergebnislos
es braucht weitere nowak will es jetzt
wissen alles